hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today's episode we're gonna
see where the rubber hits the road in
moral philosophy and I mean that quite
literally you've all heard about
self-driving cars and you may have heard
about the idea that self-driving cars
are going to have to solve the trolley
problem this famous thought experiment
in philosophy where you can either
continue to do something and several
people will die or you can take an
action to prevent your current course of
action and do something different and
fewer people will die is it okay to
intentionally kill a smaller number of
people to save a larger number of people
you might not think that this is
something you are going to need to deal
with but it's simply an illustration of
the kinds of problems that all sorts of
robots and artificial intelligences are
going to have to deal with they're going
to need to make choices and in the
extreme examples they're going to need
to make hard choices about how to cause
the least harm as one example should a
self-driving car if there are two
bicyclists in the way and it judges that
it's going to have to hit one of them
should the self-driving car target a
bicyclist with a helmet rather than one
without on the theory that wearing a
helmet makes that bicyclist more safe
and therefore in some sense that person
should get punished for wearing the
helmet that doesn't seem right
these are moral intuitions that lead to
really hard problems and we have to face
up to them today's guest Derrick Leoben
is a philosopher who has written a new
book called ethics for robots where he
tackles exactly these questions not just
self-driving cars but the general idea
of what kind of moral decision processes
should we program into our artificial
intelligences I think it's just a
fascinating topic to think about because
on the one hand Derrick's book involves
big ideas from moral philosophy
utilitarianism versus de ontology john
rolls his theory of justice things like
that on the other hand very
down-to-earth questions about game
theory the prisoner's dilemma Nash
equilibrium purrito optimality other
sort of economic and rationality
oriented ideas need to come into play
here
so to me it's a great example of how
that abstract theorizing of philosophy
suddenly becomes frighteningly relevant
to real-world decisions personally I do
not own or have plans to buy a
self-driving car in the near future but
I do think they're coming
moreover artificial intelligences of all
sorts are all around us and have an
increasing effect on our lives therefore
we should be thinking about these issues
and now's a good time as any
let's go
[Music]
Derek Leben welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks so much for having me so
this is a topic you know ethics and
morality for robots and artificial
intelligence everyone's thinking about
this we all know self-driving cars are
coming and they're gonna be apparently
running into people on the streets right
and left just deciding how many people
to hit so could you just give us your
short version of why it's necessary even
to talk about ethics or morality for
robots I mean do they even have ethics
they just do what we program them to do
yeah so that's a great place to start as
we are starting to develop more and more
autonomous technologies in the fields of
transportation medicine warfare they are
starting to make these decisions that
are going to have impacts on human
health and safety and opportunity and
for that reason we need to start
thinking about which actions are
permissible for them to do and which
actions are impermissible and I take
this to be just an inescapable fact of
designing machines that are making
complicated decisions about human
well-being that are going to be making
these decisions without very much human
supervision right we're just gonna have
to inevitably decide what kinds of rules
we want these machines to be following
now I'm not sure if we could use certain
words to talk about these machines like
responsible or not or blameworthy or not
but that's sort of beside the point for
me what I'm most interested in is what
are the rules that we're actually going
to be using to program into these
machines because that's definitely
something that we need to do yeah you
have used the word decisions as if the
robots have the ability to make
decisions is that an important word or
is it just a way of talking about the
fact that the robots are gonna be doing
something and we have to decide what we
wanted is for them to do that's
interesting for me it doesn't really
matter whether you call this a decision
or an algorithm I know that
maybe some people might think of
Decision as something performed by an
agent with free will who could have done
otherwise or something like that but for
me that's not too important I'm not
going to get hung up in those kinds of
issues and I mean certainly some moral
theories would like a Content about
ethics is going to say that only an
agent with free will who understands
what he or she is doing is capable of
being a moral agent who makes decisions
at all but that may all may already
reveal something about my my normative
assumptions that I'm making and that
that's something that I think we'll see
as we move forward that every kind of
choice you make in programming a machine
is revealing something about your
normative assumptions it's sort of
impossible to stay free of ethics to
just say well I'm going to avoid ethics
entirely right well I agree with that
very much and also I'm happy that it
doesn't matter whether we attribute
freewill to the robots because I hate
talking about freewill and yet I end up
doing it all the time so I'm glad that
we can avoid doing it for this one okay
so let's get one thing out of the way
which I'm sure you've been hit with
before
what about Isaac Asimov didn't he
explained to us how to make moral rules
for robots doesn't he have three laws
and should we just implement them yeah
so Asimov did propose these three rules
which are really just one rule and two
sort of subservient rules that say obey
people and protect yourself but the
first rule is really the one doing all
the work and it says don't cause or
allow harm to other humans now on the
face of it that's actually pretty good
and I think the reason why there's a
sort of variety of moral theories and a
variety of different kinds of rule
systems that we've constructed is that
most of them do pretty well in normal
circumstances it's a bit like I'm gonna
make the first of many analogies to
physics here because do I love I can
make analogies to physics and now's my
chance it's a bit like using classical
mechanics in most normal circumstances
where if you're
not going very fast and you're dealing
with moderately sized objects this works
really well however when you get to
these very sort of extreme situations
you start to see differences between the
moral theories and the problem with
azimoff laws is that it's vague about
certain situations like the violation of
property rights the violation of dignity
insulting people does that count as
harming them does trespassing on their
property count as harming them does
blowing smoke in someone's Direction
count as harming them and also it fails
in these situations where every action
either does or allows harm to others and
these are called moral dilemmas so in
some scenarios
you can't avoid either causing or
allowing harm to others and azimoff law
simply breaks down yeah to be perfectly
honest is the question that I asked you
was because I feel I have to ask it but
I think you're being far too generous to
Asimov's laws I think they're just silly
you know the idea that a robot cannot
through inaction allow a human being to
come to harm is entirely impractical
like human beings come to harm over the
world all the time every robot would
instantly spring into action trying to
prevent every human from stubbing his
toe right yeah exactly and this is a
point that philosophers like Peter
Singer have made for decades is that
almost everything we do in the world has
some kind of effect on people that we
might not even be aware of
I mean singer has gone to great lengths
to show that the way that we eat the way
that we travel the way that we spend our
money is actually having effects on
other people we could be doing other
things with that money with that food
perhaps driving around in our cars we're
not thinking about the damage that we're
doing to the environment into future
generations yeah and I also like the
idea that you'd need to be a little bit
more specific I think a lot of people do
have this idea that you know the example
I used in my book the big picture was in
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
we heard the moral rule that you should
just be excellent to each other
and I tried to make the point that's
fine but it's not quite good enough you
haven't told us what excellence is and
actually recently I got into a Twitter
conversation with Edie Solomon who was
the screen writer for Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure and he he was very
pleased that even if I was saying it's
not a good rule that it made it into
this kind of consideration and certainly
when robots are on the scene we have to
be a little bit more specific a little
bit more clear a little bit more
quantitative maybe about what
constitutes a morally correct action is
that right that's right and I agree that
what you're describing is a theory that
you you are familiar with virtue ethics
and it basically says do whatever a
noble person would do now this kind of
works if you have a good exemplar of a
noble person handy but then there are
all sorts of problems like how do you
know that this person is actually a
noble person whose behavior we should be
trying to imitate or not and if you are
a noble person in one culture that might
be a very very terrible person in
another culture and so that leads to
this problem that you were just talking
about which is where do we look for
these more precise more quantitative
more formal approaches to designing
moral algorithms and there's a lot of
different places one place we might look
is in human judgments and try to model
machine behavior after human behavior
another place we might look is to moral
theories and try to actually take a
historically important theory and
implement it into a machine and so yeah
in the in your book ethics robots
there's a wonderful little book everyone
can read it and it really delves into a
lot of fun things am i accurate and
saying that you contrast three major
approaches here utilitarianism
libertarianism and contract arianism
that's right yeah so I talked about some
historically influential moral theories
utilitarianism conte and ethics contract
Arianism and you could also include some
other ones you could talk about virtue
ethics if you're interested in that or
not but like I said I don't think that
to ethics is going to be specific enough
to make it into this club be a virtuous
self-driving car is hard to actually
implement in real life it is unless
you're doing something like let's train
the machine in a sort of bottom-up
approach as they say to be like human
beings around us there's actually a few
people like Wendell Wallach and Colin
Allen who have proposed that this is a
good approach to designing moral
machines however my objection to that is
that you're probably going to
incorporate all of the terrible biases
and limitations of the humans that
you're using to model your machine's
behavior on so these machines are
probably going to wind up being terribly
racist and sexist and not thinking very
clearly about consequences versus
rewards and so on and also isn't it just
a little bit circular you know to what
it means to be moral is to be like a
moral person I mean I think I'm on your
side here if I'm right that you would
say we need to be much more explicit
both for robots and for human beings
about what it objectively means to be a
moral person yes I totally agree so it
sounds like we are both on board with
virtue ethics not necessarily being a
good approach here so maybe we can move
on to what you were talking about which
is these historically important moral
theories and in your book the big
picture which I also am a fan of and I
recommend you talk a lot about how these
theories are constructed around our
moral intuitions right and there might
be different consistent internally
consistent set of sets of rules that you
could get from different kinds of moral
intuitions and I actually think that is
completely correct I think that that is
historically where these theories have
emerged from and the question is not so
much well which intuitions should we
rely on but what is I think the
evolutionary function of the intuitions
that we are using in the first place all
right so one answer to this question is
there's a lot of these different
internally consistent sets of rules that
are all more or less intuitive in some
kinds of circumstances but we have no
way of evaluating one versus the other
if somebody wants to be a utilitarian
and say it's wrong to for instance buy a
cappuccino when you should be giving
money to famine relief and another
person wants to be Con Thien and say
well your intentions when buying the
cappuccino were just to have this
delicious coffee beverage and therefore
it's only a side effect that these
people were harmed right how do we how
do we resolve the disagreement here now
you could just say well these are just
equally important and equally coherent
sets of rules but I think a better
approach is let's look at the
evolutionary function of the intuitions
that they are drawing on and say is
there a sort of unified framework that
matches that that evolutionary function
that original goal of the system right
so I mean I think - we agree on a lot of
things but maybe we disagree on the meta
ethical question of whether moral rules
are objectively real or not is that
right that's right and a lot of this
hinges on what we mean by real so I
think I mean usually does yes exactly so
when I say real I mean real in the sense
that smoking is bad for your health is a
fact it's a real fact about human beings
and it's dependent on certain goals that
we all share now this is something that
I think you're inclined to agree with
too that if we talk about morality as a
set of as the philosopher Philippa foot
once said hypothetical imperatives as a
set of sort of if-then statements if you
want to be X then you should do Y if you
want to be healthy then you should
exercise and eat right and so on then we
can have objective answers to this
question within the domain of us all
sharing these goals however I am in a
completely agree with that right yes and
so outside of these goals
we all share there's no way of talking
about one state as better or worse than
another one and that's where I think you
and Sam Harris might disagree here and
I'm on I'm on your side of that debate
he has this thought experiment that he
calls the worst possible suffering for
everyone where he says imagine everyone
is in total misery all the time clearly
that's objectively bad but I think it
only makes sense to say that that's
objectively bad if we already are within
the realm of caring about suffering and
avoiding suffering yeah I mean to me
it's it's much like saying well
aesthetic judgments are objective
because if we imagine the world's
ugliest painting everyone would agree
that it's ugly therefore must be
objective but I think that you know I
think it's okay to admit that we're
contingent human beings made of atoms
obeying the laws of physics and this
thing called our moral goals are very
reliant on historical contingent things
right like different people could have
different goals but happily we agree on
a lot and we can build from what we
agree sensible moral systems yes yes I
totally agree now the question is is
which of these internally consistent and
all apparently intuitive different sets
of rules should we select from and we're
going to have to make choices like that
because as you said in constructing a
self-driving car we're going to have to
decide which paths that result in
collisions are better and worse than
others right and it would be easy it
would be really wonderful if we could
just avoid all collisions that would be
make my job completely unnecessary and I
am fine with that
if it turns out that we can avoid any
kind of harm to anybody then we don't
need ethics at all but every time the
machine is going to be evaluating one
path and comparing it to another it's
going to have to decide which collisions
are better and worse now there's a lot
of ways of doing it it could for
instance consider the driver and the
of its vehicle as more valuable than the
other passengers it could consider
swerving to hit someone as better or
worse than continuing straight it could
view hitting and injuring more people as
better or worse than fewer people now
some of those might seem more obvious to
you or less obvious to you but the
problem is how do we actually resolve
this and I think we need a moral theory
and for that like I was saying we need
some framework of comparing these
theories and I think the only way of
doing that is by saying which moral
theory actually fulfills this meta
ethical assumption that moral theories
evolved for the purpose of promoting
cooperative behavior amongst
self-interested organisms if you have a
moral theory that actually is better at
creating cooperative behavior than other
kinds of theories then that's the one we
should use I propose in designing these
vehicles yeah maybe it's good to clear
up this issue before moving on to the
specifics of the different moral
theories there is a subjection out there
to this kind of discussion that says you
know who cares cars are not really going
to be solving trolley problems so if
they see something bad they're just
gonna hit the brakes in stop and so this
is all kind of irrelevant and I suspect
that's just an impoverished view of how
moral reasoning works and you know
people get annoyed with philosophers for
inventing trolley problems because they
say well I just don't want to play this
game but it's a way of sharpening our
intuition right and and actually be
useful here if you laid out what a
trolley problem is it's conceivable that
some of the audience doesn't know and
you also you know you mentioned in the
book that Harry Truman's decision to
drop in an atomic bomb on Japan was very
much like a trolley problem yes that's
right so these do happen and
unfortunately they happen quite often in
certain professions like in medicine and
warfare and business where you have to
make choices about causing harm to one
person or allowing harm to many other
people now this sounds very strange to
most people like me because
I think about myself as well I'm just
going through my day I'm buying
cappuccinos I'm grading papers I'm
watching Netflix what am i doing that is
causing harm to others but in fact if
you're buying that cappuccino you are
weighing your own pleasure against the
happiness and suffering of other people
who you could be donating that money to
if you're watching Netflix you could be
doing more with your time if you're
eating meat you're making judgments
about whether animals are valuable or
not and the trolley problem is one of
the scenarios that was constructed in
order to demonstrate the differences
between well initially between doing and
allowing and killing many people versus
one or I should say sacrificing one
person to save many so in the scenario
you have a runaway train going down a
track it's going to hit five people and
the only way to stop it is to either
divert it onto a side track where a
single person is or in another condition
to push a large man in front of the
train and stop the train now it turns
out that most people say it's
permissible in surveys to switch the
track on to the single person but not
permissible to push the large man to his
death even though that seems strangely
inconsistent if you are only considering
the consequences then it is the same
exact effect it's killing one to save
five but if you think that actually
performing some kind of physical
intrusion into somebody else's personal
space is important or if you think about
this in terms of a causal chain or your
intentions or something like that then
maybe there is a difference here so the
trolley problem is one way of comparing
what different moral theories might say
utilitarians will say you always kill
one to save five a lot of deontologists
what they have in common
aside from just focusing on rights and
duties is that they often say that
there's nothing wrong with just standing
back and allowing things to happen so
this is called the difference between a
positive and a negative obligation
the philosopher Robert Nozick made it a
big deal about this and said look it's
wrong of me to push you in front of a
train it's not wrong for me to allow you
to be hit by a train and so according to
most deontologists it's wrong for me to
push you in front of a train and it
might also be wrong for me to pull that
switch causing the train to go on to you
but I think that it's it's a very
helpful illuminating thought experiment
precisely because how we viscerally
think about what's morally right and
wrong might not match with what we say
we're thinking right I mean that's what
the pushing the guy off of the
footbridge really brings home that you
know if you would ask someone abstractly
is if given two choices
would you let five people die or one
person die they'll say yeah I would let
the one person die but then when you
make it concrete you have to actually
kill this one person to save the other
five they're unwilling to do it and you
know that's kind of okay and I don't
think it's irrational it's just
revealing that our moral intuitions are
not always very coherent or matching up
with our moral cognition yeah and as
someone who's taught ethics classes to
undergrads for a long time I'm very
familiar with how sort of inconsistent
people's everyday moral intuitions are
you know if you press just a little bit
on some of these trolley problems like
well it's okay to pull the switch and in
fact you should pull the switch to kill
one but it's to say if I but what if it
was your mother or your father or your
best friend on a sidetrack well then
people change their minds and then you
ask them well why do you think it's okay
for you to value your parents over other
people's parents is surely these people
are equally valuable you're not saying
that your family is actually better than
other people's families but it turns out
that people's moral judgments actually
are sensitive to this there was a
fantastic experiment done by some
researchers led by April bless key
rechak and they found that alternating
by condition the genetic relatedness of
the person on the side track will
alternate whether people are willing to
pull the switch almost exactly as you
would predict by the proportion of their
genetic relatedness
rather a cousin and so on right but what
is the most joke I would I would
sacrifice you know my brother or sister
to save two cousins or something like
that yeah exactly I think that was a
quote from was it Herbert Spencer or
something yeah that's right and so that
but most moral theories agree that
genetic relatedness should not play a
role and in fact if you press people and
ask well are you saying that people who
are genetically related to you are
better than the people who are not
genetically related to you they'll say
well of course not that's silly I would
never say that but by acting in that way
they are revealing that judgment is is
actually playing a role in their
behavior yeah and I think that again
part of it is that a lot of people have
a presumption whether it's explicit or
implicit that the right kind of ultimate
moral theory will be something
utilitarian but maybe it's not like
maybe it's perfectly okay
or at least let's let's say not maybe
but let's say I can imagine a perfectly
coherent moral theory that very
explicitly gives more credit to people
who are closer to me when I come to
saving lives yeah exactly so I mean the
utilitarian has to say some really
really weird things but the other moral
theories also sometimes have to say some
really really weird things and this is
what you have to get used to is that no
consistent set of rules is going to give
you everything that you want all the
time and my theory that I'm advocating
also tells me some things that I really
don't like and I think is really weird
why don't why don't we give you a chance
to explain what your theory is which is
not completely yours you you know we've
building on quite a tradition here
that's right so I am advocating a moral
theory that is drawn from a tradition
called contract Arianism and the most
recent version of this that I'm using
was from a philosopher an American
philosopher named John Rawls and in his
book a theory of justice from 1971 he
proposed that the best way of designing
a fair society is to imagine that we
were in this original position where I
know who I'm going to be I could be
anyone and in this kind of idealized
bargaining position he thought we would
all come to agree on certain basic
distributions of what he called primary
Goods and the distinction between
primary Goods and secondary Goods are
that when you don't know who you're
going to be you don't know if you're
going to be male or female tall or short
handicapped or perfectly abled and so on
and if that's the case you don't know
what kinds of particular things are
gonna value are you gonna like
television or you're gonna like coffee
maybe maybe not these are all secondary
goods primary goods are the kinds of
things that all human beings value no
matter what that all human beings have
to value in order to pursue any kind of
goal at all and this list includes
things like your life your health your
opportunity and essential resources for
survival so no matter what you want to
do with your life if you want to be a
juggler if you want to be a lawyer if
you want to be a physicist you need to
have essential resources opportunities
and health right and so yep going back
to our previous discussion these are the
kinds of things that we have as you
could call them common ground that all
human beings as a matter of fact just by
virtue of being human beings care about
and if someone says well I don't value
these things I could say yes you do
you're a human being and you pursue
goals and so you care about your health
and safety and opportunity you know I
actually took a class with John roles in
graduate school really yes it was very
funny because i well i audited the class
but i went to those sections and
everything and I remember one day
walking with a friend of mine across
campus and the people who had actually
taken the class for a grade were coming
out of the final exam and I just ran
into them and so I said hey you know how
the exam go and they were like it's very
fair which of course my friend who is
like that must not be your physics
friends those must be your philosophy
friends because no physics people I've
ever
come out of an exam saying that was very
fair but rolls his whole thing was
justice as fairness and tried to make
things as fair to everyone as possible
that's right and Rawls is primarily
known as a political philosopher because
the kinds of things he was talking about
designing from this original position
were mainly policies and the structure
of our government and social
institutions however towards the end of
the book he talks a little bit about
using this as a framework for individual
decision making and that's what I want
to be doing I want to say that we can
also use this as a way of thinking about
what kinds of actions are wrong and what
kinds of actions are permissible from
the original position Rahl said we would
all agree on a certain distribution
principle that he called the maximun
principle and the maximun principle has
a history from game theory and in this
context it just means we would agree on
a distribution which makes the poorest
person as best off as possible yeah
actually I do want to get into this but
I realized now while you're saying this
there's a prior thing I want to just
touch on very quickly you mentioned the
fact that I think that rolls himself
would have cast his theory as a
political one right a way to organize
our society in fact only a well-ordered
society right I mean he admits that
there would be cases where things were
in extreme distress where you'd have to
violate his principles but he the idea
as I understood it was that we could
disagree on basic moral conceptions but
if we agreed to live together in a
liberal democratic polity then he had
these rules for how to reconcile our
different moral conceptions and so
you're going a little bit farther
because you want to actually use this as
a theory of morality as well right
that's right well I want to say that
there are many kinds of values that are
equally comparable to each other
however those all exist within a kind of
space that is constrained by essentially
this moral decision procedure so there
are lots of equally good distributions
according to the maximun principle
within that space of equally good
distributions of primary Goods then we
could go ahead and impose many different
kinds of values and have interesting
disagreements about which sets of values
are the ones that are best but
importantly that's all occurring within
the space of a sort of maxime end
constraint but it is a little bit it's
asking you a bit more right because the
original position is something where we
forget some things about ourselves like
you said and we remember other things
ourselves the difference between primary
versus secondary goals and the this
seems potentially more problematic if we
want to get out of it moral rules rather
than just a political system I mean if
someone is in real life very religious
and has some religious convictions that
strongly flavor their ideas of right and
wrong are those convictions things they
will have to forget in the original
position yes isn't that wouldn't that
lead them to something that's a moral
theory coming out of the original
position that is very different than the
one they actually have probably yes but
I don't think we need John Rawls to
convince us that religion is irrelevant
to ethics I think just some basic
assumptions about what we mean by making
moral choices can do that and this goes
back to the dialogue Euthyphro by Plato
where he plausibly demonstrated that
look even if God were to say that
slavery and child abuse and rape are
morally good that doesn't make them good
and so usually when I'm talking to
somebody who thinks that morality is
based on a certain set of religious
beliefs it takes about 90 seconds of
talking to them to get them to finally
admit well yeah I guess you're right
that it doesn't really matter what the
religious text says what matters is
something else I think that I'm I'm on
board with the I can never pronounce it
Euthyphro oh you Thoreau yea Euthyphro
dilemma and why there should be some of
it some criteria for morality other than
what God says but nevertheless I think
that I could imagine that the actual
moral beliefs that a religious person
has
they're different not because God gave
them the moral beliefs but because their
religious beliefs affect how they think
about the world right how they think
about the ontology of reality if you
believe that human life begins at
conception you might have different
views on abortion than if you believe
it's just a bunch of cells obeying the
laws of biology yeah that's interesting
I I think it's the abortion case is
difficult and in fact people often when
they're talking about ethics jump right
to abortion which is one of the most
complicated moral topics and I usually
like to point out well you're you're
basically starting off at the into
introduction of the book and just
skipping right to the most complicated
problem at the very end right there's a
lot of stuff that goes on in between and
most problems that we face are actually
I think ones that are plausibly ones
that have good moral answers to them
like as I mentioned slavery child abuse
rape and then of course we get to more
difficult cases like charity and eating
animals and driving a fossil fuel
vehicle which I think are in fact things
that most people think are maybe morally
permissible or wrong and are probably
mistaken about and then we get to very
very difficult cases like abortion which
even if there is not an answer to that
and I think there there is probably an
answer to it but even if there is not
that doesn't invalidate everything that
sort of went up to that point okay but
you know I'm just trying to get on the
table the idea that when we when we get
back to the self-driving car is killing
people solving their little trolley
problems as they're going down the
street I could at least imagine that
people have deep-seated moral
convictions that wouldn't qualify in
roles as conception as primary Goods and
they might object to having those
conceptions stripped away from them as
we put them in the original position I
think that's correct
but I also think it's correct that any
group of people who are interacting with
each other are
going to have certain beliefs that are
not respected in the process of sort of
interacting and so if we are having a
civil society together just to take the
political case then inevitably some of
your beliefs are probably going to come
into conflict with other people's
beliefs and with the institution so if I
have a religious objection to say oh I
don't know respecting other people of
different races then you're going to say
as a government no you actually have to
treat everybody equally and it doesn't
matter what your religious beliefs are
right yeah no I think that the the
reason that I harp on this is I've
become very very interested in this
potential conflict between fundamental
moral positions that individuals might
have and the goal that we presumably
share of living in a liberal democratic
society I think that we tend to paper
over them these differences a little bit
but I think they we should respect that
they could be true conflicts and have to
eventually say something like what you
just said which is that yeah you know
suck it up some people are gonna have to
have that make compromises if we're
gonna live together like this yeah I
totally agree and I I think instead of
phrasing it I mean I would also say suck
it up but that's sort of the the
Pittsburgh and me I think that that a
more congenial way of phrasing that is
that you might have very different
religious values from me but there are a
set of values that we all share and what
we need to base a moral theory on is the
sort of universal ground that we all
have in common the kinds of things that
enable all human beings to pursue their
goals you're right that's a much more
public relations friendly way of putting
before I think that it's a wise way of
doing it okay so I know you want to get
to the maximum principle so do i but
maybe even before we do that I was I
really liked in your book the casting
things in terms of game theory and
prisoners dilemmas and Nash equilibria
and Pareto optimality and all these
other buzz words and I think that you
know this is why we have an hour-long
podcast so we can actually explain a
little bit how you're thinking because
it's a very
helpful conceptual tool so why is game
theory something that is useful tool to
have in mind when we think about these
issues yeah I am really excited to talk
about this because I think this is the
way forward in resolving these kinds of
tensions between different consistent
moral theories this kind of tool was
only available to philosophers for the
last 50 60 years or so a lot of times
when I tell people that I work on
designing moral frameworks for machines
they'll say well haven't philosophers
been doing this for thousands of years
and they haven't gotten anywhere now my
first response is well just because a
problem has been around for a long time
doesn't mean it can't be solved and the
second response is actually that I think
the tools for solving these kinds of
problems have really only emerged in the
last 50 or 60 years or so and when we
talk about evaluating theories based on
which one promotes cooperative behavior
there's been a lot of talk in the
history of philosophy about promoting
cooperation the British philosopher
Thomas Hobbes talks a lot about if we
didn't have any kinds of rules we would
need to invent ones in order to
cooperate you and I have been talking
about living in a civil society and
cooperating together but exactly what
does this mean when we talk about
cooperation well there is a very very
technical way of describing this and you
can describe it as a kind of improvement
from simple self-interested behavior
self-interest is actually a very
powerful tool and in the 1950s John Nash
described a certain method of describe
of showing how self-interested agents
would come to certain equilibria in
interactions in games with each other
and of course games doesn't just mean
poker and blackjack but it can just mean
any situation where two or more people
are interacting and there are gains and
losses for those people but poker was a
big influence right that was a bit
that's right well it also includes games
too yeah so what we're talking about
here are cases
where the prisoner's dilemma is usually
phrased in terms of sort of cops and
robbers drama where let's say that I
arrest you for drug dealing and I know
you're dealing drugs but I don't have
enough evidence to convict you now I
make you a deal you and your partner a
deal in separate rooms I say look if you
will confess to the crime I'll let you
off free but I'm gonna put your partner
away for good and you know if you both
stay quiet that you actually get let's
say a very low sentence if both of you
confess you both get a medium sentence
and it turns out in this kind of
scenario a lot of people might think
it's intuitive that you should stay
quiet
but according to Nash you should both
confess you should both squeal on each
other now what's weird about this is
you've got a conflict where it turns out
there is an improvement if both of you
confess to the crime then you both get a
low sentence but or I'm sorry a medium
sentence but if both of you were to stay
quiet you would have both gotten a low
sentence now that's what's called a
Pareto improvement because it is
improvement for everyone it doesn't make
anyone worse off and these are the kinds
of improvements that economists think
are the bare minimum for rationality
like if I finish my lunch and you're
hungry and you're sitting next to me
I've still got some leftovers it seems
obvious that I should just give some to
you it doesn't make me any worse off and
it makes you better off it's a Pareto
improvement
it's from the Italian economist vilfredo
pareto and so I'm defining cooperation
problems as ones where self-interest
here and self-interest I'm measuring as
a Nash equilibrium in fact there are
lots of different situations that have
different kinds of Nash equilibria you
could have multiple Nash equilibria but
there exist Pareto improvements from
Nash equilibria and because I understand
it correctly the Nash equilibrium is one
where one
person cannot unilaterally change to get
a better outcome without hurting
somebody else but a Pareto improvement
would be where if we all change at once
we will all be better off as that that's
exactly right and that's the challenge
is that Pareto improvements from these
Nash equilibria are not things that
self-interested rational agents can do
they're not capable of it and so the
operation problem exactly there's a
problem and this is the challenge that
Thomas Hobbes and the 1600s was
describing is that people in their own
self-interest are going to be led to
these outcomes that are actually not
optimal for everyone and so we need this
sort of third party as he called it a
Leviathan or maybe a set of rules or a
government to come in and force us to
act in a way that's for everybody's
mutual benefit right and being as you
just alluded to being Pareto optimal is
kind of something that nobody could
disagree with right yeah it's not
necessarily the final answer to our
right thing to do but if there is
something where if everyone acted in a
certain way literally everybody would be
better off or or at least the same then
how could anyone object to that right
exactly and it's the kind of thing that
you would expect in the evolutionary
history of our species and other species
as well would motivate certain adaptive
traits to emerge would actually lead
certain traits to emerge to force us to
cooperate in places where we wouldn't
have cooperated before and I liked that
and you go on to propose the repugnant
prisoner's dilemma as an illustration of
how straightforward utilitarianism can
lead us wrong and it's kind of a version
of the utility monster thought
experiment that I guess was it Nozick
who proposed that yeah and we're you
know if one person can become way better
off and everyone else suffers just a
little bit straightforward
utilitarianism would say yeah sure you
know like let everyone suffer just a
little bit because this one person would
be so much better off and you would
argue that that's probably not the moral
strategy we want to pursue that's right
the great thing about defining
cooperation in this very formal sense is
that we could actually go on and test
which of our moral theories produce more
and less cooperative solutions so I
think that in most cases like the
prisoner's dilemma the regular
prisoner's dilemma it turns out that
utilitarianism contract Arianism natural
rights theories Conti and ethics they
all produce the correct result they all
produce mutual cooperation which is
great and I think our moral intuitions
this sort of mixed bag of cognitive
mechanisms that have over time evolved
to make these kinds of choices that they
also in most situations do a great job
of promoting cooperative behavior but
you accept that except maybe
libertarianism does not get the same
answer for the iterated prisoner's
dilemma
maybe yeah it depends on how you define
causing the harm so if you this is
something that Nozik talks a lot about
in Anarchy state and utopia which was
his rebuttal in the 70s to to Rawls
he said that if you're talking about
causing harm as sort of doing something
where if you had done otherwise she
would have been worse off than in this
case maybe the prisoner's dilemma is not
an instance of causing harm to the other
person if you confess or if you stay
quiet but it's it's difficult to say in
that scenario really what counts as
causing harm but but nevertheless I
think I take your point that for the
conventional prisoner's dilemma we have
a Nash equilibrium where everyone
defects but most sensible people would
say that both players in the game are
better off if they cooperate and so we
can have that as a starting point of
agreement and work from there yeah and
it's even more than most sensible people
it's overtime if you are a utilitarian
or a contract Arian playing prisoner's
dilemma over and over and over again you
will get better outcomes if you're
measuring this in money you'll make more
money over time if you're measuring this
in chilled
you'll have more children over time
right okay so now I'm gonna finally let
you tell us what a good contract Aryan
believes I mean you mentioned the
maximun principle but how is it
different how would a good contract
Aryan approach something like a
prisoner's dilemma or other sorts of
games differently than a straightforward
utilitarian would write so the maximun
principle says that we should prefer the
distribution that makes the worst off
person as best off as possible and
usually what that means is you have a
set of outcomes you attach values to
each of those outcomes number values and
in each of the outcomes you pick the
worst off then you put those into a
group and select the highest of the lows
and that's the one you pick now in terms
of distribution of money that's fairly
straightforward how you count and
quantify those distributions but in
terms of other kinds of goods it might
be a little more complicated
however utilitarians have been spending
years decades centuries to try to
convince us that pleasures and pains can
be quantified and counted and I think
what up and add it up that's right and
so the utilitarian wants to run
essentially a summation function over
all of this and just pick the highest of
the sums now those usually produce very
similar answers so in the prisoner's
dilemma it turns out that adding up all
the outcomes and running maxime n both
say that we should cooperate with each
other right but in other scenarios you
could arrange it and I mentioned or you
mentioned the repugnant prisoner's
dilemma that I set up you could arrange
scenarios where the sum of all the
payoffs for people is actually not
either
what maxy men would say nor is it what
Pareto optimality would predict over
just self-interested behavior and for
that reason I think that the maximum
principle is actually the better
principal than the utilitarian one and
it's precisely because this possibility
that there could be great gains for
one person but other people have to
suffer because of it exactly and that's
almost a prediction of the theory not
necessarily a motivation for it the real
motivation for it is that it produces
cooperative behavior in all scenarios
where the prediction is that it will
make the worst off as well off as
possible usually this makes a lot of
sense intuitively so in a in a like you
said a liberal democracy very often
progressives are wanting to benefit the
poor before we benefit the rich that
they should have priority so this is
often called a priority Rhian principle
however there are some other situations
where it wouldn't be priority Rhian I
think the real where the rubber meets
the road here is when you start actually
attaching values to outcomes and you
have to do that by saying here are the
primary Goods what I was saying earlier
are the kinds of goods that all human
beings from the original position would
care about our health our safety our
opportunity and you try to quantify them
and then calculate the effects of your
action on those Goods yeah so if I say
look if I'm going to punch you in the
face I might get some amount of pleasure
from that if I'm some sadistic weirdo I
don't want to do that but if I did but
it would be terrible in terms of your
health and opportunity and that lost to
you in primary Goods is not equivalent
or not made up for the gain to me in the
secondary goods that I get namely my my
pleasure or something like that and so
when we talk about applying this to
self-driving cars what we need to do is
we need to have a way of quantifying the
effects of every collision on the health
and safety of the passengers of
pedestrians of people in other cars and
then what a contract Arian would do is
run a maximun function over all of that
and say here are three different
collisions what are the worst health
outcomes in each of these collisions and
I'm going to pick the best of the
worst-case scenarios
the so that sounds like something
sensible but just before we dig into
that I think it's safe to say that in
the political sphere where Rawls was
originally talking about his reasoning
does seem to lead us to quite a
redistributive way of running society
right the very worse off people have to
be improved by any inequality that we
allow so it's a very different world
than where we actually live we're in
modern capitalism in the United States
there's plenty of people suffering a lot
with the idea that you know there's
other people who are doing really well
off because of economic growth and and
that's a what a trade-off we're willing
to make that's right now if you are
utilitarian you care very much about the
suffering of these other people so you
use the word suffering but if I'm a
contract Arian I don't care about their
suffering I care about the distribution
of primary goods namely their health
their safety their essential resources
and so what I care about is making sure
that the worst off people in the
population are brought up to a minimal
level of let's just call it normal
functioning right now there's a lot of
discussion about this in bioethics about
what is normal functioning how do we
quantify normal functioning but that's
essentially what a contract harian is
trying to do to bring everybody up to a
minimal threshold of opportunity and
safety but not happiness in fact
contract Aryans don't care about
happiness happiness is not the the good
that we are calculating well but for
Rawls certainly wealth that you an
individual has would be among the goods
that we do calculate right when we talk
about or the difference principle saying
that inequalities should only be allowed
and to the extent that everyone is
better off wealth is among the things
that makes us better off sure but only
to the extent that wealth is able to get
you the essential resources you need to
pursue goals if you are a masochist and
you enjoy suffering that's fine as long
as you have enough essential resources
to continue being a masochist then
that's all a contract aryan cares about
sure that's right I'm just trying to you
know there
I'm just trying to because when we get
to the self-driving cars there will be
competing conceptions of what the cars
should be doing so I just want people to
know they're analogous competing
conceptions in the political arena you
know a Rolls Ian at least at face value
would be much more democratic socialist
whereas a libertarian would be much more
capitalist in terms of how the economy
should run itself right and these are
both plausible theories that we can
argue about that's right yes good so
then we when we come to the cars you're
going to try to implement some kind of
maxi min algorithm in the mind of a
self-driving car that's right so I think
there needs to be a database of
collisions and the effects of these
collisions on most people of comparable
let's say size and position right now
this is something that you might think
is really really complicated and even
maybe a little bit silly but I think the
alternative is even sillier so right now
a lot of the major car companies have
the official position of just saying
well we think all collisions are bad and
we want to avoid them all equally but I
think that's an incredibly ridiculous
position to take because not all
collisions are equal obviously getting
hit by a vehicle moving at 2 miles an
hour is better than getting hit by a
vehicle moving at 20 miles an hour and I
want vehicles that are evaluating
different paths to say that one
collision is better than another yeah no
I think that I don't even quite
understand the resistance to this way of
thinking I mean if someone says what is
the best economic system and someone
else said well is this system where
everybody is wealthy that would not be
very convincing to anyone you're like
well that's not the world that we have
to make some hard choices here at the
cars or we should at least anticipate
the reality that cars are going to be
making some hard choices I think that's
the reality that is slowly coming but I
think it's sort of a public relations
nightmare for an industry that is
already working hard to just convince
people that these things are safe
at all much less to convince them that
they should be evaluating which kinds of
collisions are better and worse and
there is I think a point I think that
you made this point in the book there
hadn't quite sunk into my brain before
reading it which is that neither you the
human driver nor the car the artificial
intelligence can say with perfect
certainty what the outcome of a decision
is going to be therefore even if it's
rare that someone actually gets run over
a car will constantly be talking will be
making decisions between higher risk and
lower risk actions and that is really
quite down-to-earth and and it could be
common right that's right I mean I've
talked to a few people who are designing
autonomous systems in the in mostly in
academics not in the industry industry
doesn't want to talk at all about this
kind of stuff and I can understand why
but a lot of the people in academics who
are working on this technology I talked
to for instance Benjamin Kuiper's who is
building along with his former postdoc
Shan Shan Park they built this wonderful
autonomous robot that moves around the
halls of the University of Michigan and
detects obstacles and slows down and
tries to avoid them and park used this
system called model predictive control
where it essentially casts out a net of
many many many possible paths many per
second and then prunes those paths based
on the likelihood that each of them is
going to result in a collision now
likelihood is a really great method to
evaluate paths right I want to take the
paths that are least likely to result in
collisions but once again I think we
need more than just likelihood I think
we also need to say a likely collision
with a pedestrian is worse than a likely
pedestrian collision with a tree right
yeah exactly so I mean is there how
simple and straightforward does this
suggest algorithm become when it comes
to things like trolley problems or
things like babies versus grownups or
anything like that I mean there still
seems to be a lot of wishy-washy miss
there yeah so it will tell us what kinds
of information is relevant in making
this database in the first place which i
think is really important
so there was a recent experiment
conducted by the MIT Media Lab that
you're probably familiar with it was
just published in Nature a couple weeks
ago and it was called the moral machine
experiment yes and so what they did is
they asked people to make choices about
self-driving car trolley problems where
they alternated things like the genders
the the age the social status of all the
people involved so would you rather run
over to doctors and a homeless person to
save one obese man and the dog or
something like that now the contract
Aryan as well as most moral theories are
going to say all of that information is
irrelevant or most of it is irrelevant
so whether a person is a doctor or a
lawyer whether a person is a Muslim or a
Christian or an atheist all of that is
irrelevant but what is relevant are
things like your physical position your
physical size and maybe your age because
that information actually tells us about
the effects of this collision with you
and so this is important in figuring out
what what kinds of databases are gonna
be discriminatory against people and
what kinds are not well you brought up
this very interesting question do you
discriminate against people on
motorcycles who are wearing helmets
versus those who are not because
presumably a collision with someone
wearing a helmet will hurt them less
than someone not wearing a helmet so we
actually punish them in some sense yeah
and that's one of the more
counterintuitive predictions of my
theory my theory says a lot of things
that I find pretty intuitive but a few
things that I find counterintuitive and
unfortunately if my theory is correct I
just have to say well so much the worse
for my intuitions here part of the
problem might be the use of the word
punish so that's a little bit misleading
if the car is going to evaluate a
collision with a bicyclist without a
helmet as worse than a collision with a
bicyclist with a helmet that doesn't
mean that it hates the one with a helmet
or that it thinks that the
without a helmet deserves to die more
than the one without a helmet it's only
saying this path is less dangerous than
that path and the reason why I agree
with you that seems really weird is that
you think well the person with the
helmet was being safe she's the one who
left the house that day taking
precautions
why should she have the car target her
or punish her more than the other one
and the answer is I think we need to
stop using words like target or punish
and just say that the path that leads to
you was evaluated as better than the
path that led to her okay good and so I
think yeah there's two big looming
questions I'm not quite clear on here
yet but I think we can clear them up one
is you seem to be saying that the
contract area and just treats every
human being equally right roughly
speaking maybe there's some health
differences like maybe a strong person
is wouldn't be as bad to get an accident
with as a weak person because they're
more likely to survive it but this is
contrary to how many people's intuition
goes one of the aspects of the MIT study
if I remember correctly was that
different people from different parts of
the world gave different answers for
injuring you know women versus men young
people versus old people etc but you're
saying that you're advocating being
ignorant over all of that that's right
so if people are preferring to collide
with men over women my response would be
that sexism and that's not something we
want to incorporate into our machine
right good and but so some people are
not going to agree with this right
you're gonna have to try to convince
them but that's okay well yeah so I have
to keep stepping back until we find some
grounds that we could agree on so I'll
step back one step and say okay well
what moral theory are you using and in
just about any moral theory
you're not going to value men more than
women or vice versa not utilitarianism
not Conti and ethics nothing and if they
say they still do well to take a further
step back and say okay well how should
we even make decisions in the world
right should we just base off of the
things that we all have in common
and if we're agreeing on that then I'm
going to say contract harrion ism is the
best way of cooperating based on the
values that we all share but okay what
about babies versus grown-ups baby's
worth versus grownups is difficult
because a grown-up and when we're just
talking about collisions is more likely
to survive a crash not a baby and so in
that case the baby should be preferred
but not because we love babies more or
they're more adorable but because they
are more vulnerable okay that makes
sense
good and then the other looming issue
was you know let's be explicit about how
we come down on the various trolley
problem kind of scenarios here it sounds
like contract Arianism doesn't really
care if one person versus five gets
injured because of an active choice
versus a passive one right it's just it
is a consequentialist point of view at
the end of the day yeah that's right
that's right so I do think we need to
evaluate outcomes based on the
distributions they produce and that is a
kind of consequentialism and so in that
way I think utilitarianism and contract
arianism are sort of cousins in this
respect but I think the biggest
difference is their way of quantifying
the goods do they quantify happiness and
suffering or primary goods and do they
run a summation function or a maximun
function right and so in say the trolley
problem in most cases they're going to
agree but in some cases they're gonna
disagree and in some cases I find it
really weird so here's here's one of
those one of those cases so according to
my theory this is something that a
friend of mine the philosopher Susan
Anderson pointed out she pointed out
that according to maxi men it would be
better for the car to swerve into a
crowd of 50 people and give them all a
broken leg rather than to swerve into a
brick wall and give the passenger in the
vehicle two broken legs why is that
because 50 broken 50 broken legs is or
rather 50 single broken legs is better
than one in
of two broken legs and I find that so
strange I find that crazy but once again
I just have to say just like jeremy
bentham did in the 1700s well my theory
says it so I have to accept it jeremy
bentham was talking about homosexuality
and he said according to my theory I
guess it's alright even though according
to him it was really weird and gross he
had to accept it well I I mean I I agree
with what the consequences are sometimes
when our moral theories give us highly
counterintuitive or weird sounding
suggestions we need to say well maybe I
have the wrong moral theory right well
that's actually something that Rawls
thought so Rawls agreed that we need to
go through this process called
reflective equilibrium right where we
sort of tune our own intuitions to the
theories that we are developing however
that's where I think I would diverge
from Rawls I would say that look if
there's a matter of fact about which
actions create more cooperative behavior
than others then just like if the doctor
tells me to stop smoking and I really
really want to I have to say well look
it's a matter of fact which actions are
right and wrong or which actions are
healthy and unhealthy but I could still
say I don't want to do that or even I'm
not going to do that however there's
still a fact of the matter about what
the right thing to do is right but you
know we do need to make some choice
about whether or not we've discovered
that fact of the matter through our
moral theorizing or whether or not we
should be a little bit less confident
that you know you you've chosen a
function right a utilitarian chooses a
function overall utility which is to say
add it all up and maximize it and you've
in some sense chosen a function over
utility which is to say look at the
utility of the worse off person and
maximize that right and maybe there's
some happy medium so that the 50 people
don't get their legs broken I don't see
how that would work although I'm open to
thinking about it so there are a lot of
people who want to sort of have hybrid
versions between these two
but once again the problem is if you
want to mix the two theories together I
think you need to have a third theory
that tells you when do you take the
utilitarian choice when do you take the
contract Aryan choice and I just don't
know what that third Theory would look
like well you say that now when the
fifty people are suing you because they
all have their legs broken you might
feel differently no no don't say that
yeah actually someone at a conference
recently joked to me that if if I'm
wildly successful beyond my dreams and
this actually was used in self-driving
cars I could be responsible for millions
of injuries and deaths and I laughed
because I know that that's not going to
happen right but there was a part of me
that sort of was a little bit afraid I
mean I know that the car companies need
to work out some kind of solution to
this and the problem is they're not
talking about what they're doing yeah I
mean you could equally well say that if
you succeed beyond your wildest dreams
you'll be responsible for saving
enormous amounts of death and suffering
in the world right sure sure so let me
ask you if you don't mind are you I
assume you're sort of taking the more
utilitarian approach here I got from
what you were what you were saying that
generally you take a sort of utilitarian
although utilitarian constructivist from
your from your big picture book but
still more or less good old-fashioned
utilitarian approach to most kinds of
decisions like this actually no I'm just
trying to give you a hard time because I
just trying to figure out what the right
thing to do is I don't really have
strong substantive moral theory myself
like I don't believe in utilitarianism
because I totally buy the utility
monster kind of responses or the
repugnant conclusion I mean Derek Parfit
had this very similar argument that it
would always be better just to have more
children just had like more and more
killed kids because there can be more
and more people having happiness and I'm
extraordinarily skeptical of the idea
that we can number one calculate
individual utility for people maybe
that's possible but then number two add
them up on some commensurable scale
seems like the wrong thing to do to me
so I'm almost to the point where I
willing to accept some kind of day
ontology rather than some kind of
consequentialist way of thinking but I'm
not quite sure what that would be that's
interesting so you mentioned two
objections to utilitarianism one of them
is that it doesn't match your intuitions
on some weird cases and the other one is
that it's just very very hard to
implement it's hard to calculate
pleasures and pains right now if I'm a
utilitarian I might say as to the first
one well so much the worse for your
intuitions and in addition I might point
out now I'm being a utilitarian for some
reason but I might also point out that
any moral theory is going to say really
really counterintuitive things so I'm
not sure why we should care if there's a
crazy sounding scenario with an alien
where it doesn't seem to match our
intuitions do we do you expect that
there's going to be a moral theory that
matches all of your intuitions at some
point no but I actually do by Rawls's
point on reflective equilibrium because
as a moral anti-realist I think that
we're getting our starting point for
morality are our moral intuitions as a
cognitive realist I understand that
those intuitions might be incoherent and
therefore there's work for moral
philosophy to do in from our moral
intuitions building them into the best
fit sensible logical coherent system but
I think so I think it's evidence when
the system that I've tried to build is
while the in conflict with the
intuitions I started with that might be
either because I gotta get rid of that
intuition or because I did a bad job
building a system I'm open to both
possibilities I think that's fair I
think that's fair I think my main
concern about using intuitions in
evaluating the theory is that I'm so
aware of the history of strong
intuitions that have been false sure
that I just give them virtually no
evidential weight whatsoever I mean in
addition to that you know there's a lot
of intuitions I have right now that I
suspect almost any moral theory is going
to tell me or is wrong like I said I
love the taste of meat yeah but any
plausible moral theory is going to tell
me that if I can lead a happy healthy
life without
meet that I really should I love driving
fossil fuel vehicles I love it but most
moral theories tell me that if that has
terrible effects on the environment and
I really don't need to be doing that I
live in a city yeah I have public
transport so again most moral theories
are gonna tell me things I really don't
want to hear and no I definitely agree
we have to be open to throwing out this
or that moral intuition or at least
dramatically changing it and I think
this is what makes human beings pretty
cool is that we don't only have our
moral intuitions I mean they're where we
start but we also have our rational
cognitive capabilities and we can
there's feedback right we can go from
rationality to alter our moral feelings
and you know it could happen like I'm a
I'm a meat-eater and I Drive a fossil
fuel car I want to get rid of the fossil
fuel car but I don't I'm not gonna get
rid of eating the meat but I'd be
happier if we could make artificial meat
and you know wouldn't have to kill any
animals to do it sure I could see that I
mean and the problem in appealing to
pure or rational sort of Corrections
here is that if there's nothing outside
of our intuitions that we're appealing
to to correct them then I'm not sure how
we escape the inevitability of an
internally coherent system that's just
completely mistaken yeah I don't
necessarily believe that the word
mistaken has any referent there in the
world I think that yeah I can understand
that I think I think then we're just
coming to blows about whether we think
the function of moral theories is to
produce cooperative behavior among
self-interested organisms or whether
it's to produce sort of satisfying
solutions according to our contingent
intuitions that we all have an issue or
some of us happen to share yeah I think
that in both senses we're trying to be
you know coherent and rational either
individually or collectively so I think
it's it's you know it's interesting to
me is that people have strong
disagreements about moral realism versus
anti-realism and those disagreements are
almost entirely uncorrelated with their
ideas about what actually is and is not
moral that is really fascinating to me -
I find that in talking to most sort of
well-educated people in my friends
circles that they are explicitly moral
relativists but implicitly utilitarians
interesting and yeah well usually like
you said in the sort of good
utilitarians where they want they're
willing to sacrifice one person to save
many but then they also don't want to
sacrifice cappuccinos and fossil-fuel
and eating meat and so on right and so
if you push them far enough maybe
they'll admit that explicitly but then
they might fall back on relativism and
say well it's all relative or something
like that
well the relative when it's convenient
yeah for me utilitarianism is an example
of something that I reads into myself
out of as far as I'm concerned you know
I think that it sounds superficially
like the right thing to do but I think
the objections to it are good enough
that I'm looking for something better
yeah I'm just in case you're curious I
was going to bring this in I have a
survey that was conducted by the the
website philpapers org run by David
Chalmers and his group and they asked
professional philosophers do you accept
the category of normative ethics
described as consequentialism deontology
or virtue ethics right and it's it's
roughly split as 25% acceptor lean
deontology 23% and some change accept or
lean towards consequentialism 18%
towards virtue ethics and 32.3%
other and this actually reminds me of a
a poll that you took and you described
in one of your blog posts about your
survey of interpretations of quantum
mechanics yep not we're in census yeah
not a lot of consensus and you you
called this a huge embarrassment for the
field of physics and I kind of feel that
way about my own field in some ways I
must admit I feel like it is a little
embarrassing that these are not just
theories that are sort of fun to think
about but they actually make a
difference in how we live and
how we design artificial intelligence
and it turns out that there's not a lot
of consensus in the field where there
should be do you have the numbers there
for moral realism versus anti-realism I
actually might yeah hold on a sec is
that that was also a philpapers
survey question I remember that yeah I
think most philosophers are realists
right that's right 56 point for acceptor
lean towards realism 27.7 anti and then
15% other all right I mean it's it is
interesting I think it's more
embarrassing that we don't have a
consensus on quantum mechanics because
quantum mechanics should be easier then
ethics or morality but it's more
important that we don't have a consensus
on ethics or morality right that's where
the analogy might end is that most of
the versions of quantum mechanics if I
understand it make essentially similar
predictions
however the moral theories although one
could say in 99% of cases most of the
moral theories probably make the same
predictions it's just these rare
scenarios of especially involving say
opportunity cost but you could be doing
instead of what you're doing right now
that there's the biggest and most
important disagreements sure and if
you're in that crowd of 50 people is
going to if their legs broken it's
extremely relevant to you that they
don't sorry programmed one way or the
other so just a you know sort of wrap it
up put a bow on it I guess we glossed
over a little bit about the
implementable 'ti of this plan I mean
you sketched out a sort of a database
idea where we would have all these
different possibilities how real-world
is this prospect of making contract
Arianism the way that our self-driving
cars go about making moral decisions
yeah that's a terrific question and my
answer is I don't know but if you are
working on this kind of technology out
there I would love to hear from you I
want to know how plausible is it to be
able to design autonomous vehicles and
other autonomous systems that can
quantify the effects of these actions on
primary Goods and then run maximan
functions over them right I've talked to
people in the field who say well
seems like this might be plausible I see
my job as saying if we are going to
design autonomous systems here's what
they need to be capable of doing and if
they are not capable of doing this then
we should slow down or maybe even halt
the development of this technology right
right and I think that's especially
relevant in the domain of autonomous
weapon systems well good I want to so
the in here my final two questions which
could be short answers or longer but one
of them is you brought up an issue in
the book that again I was sort of hadn't
I was surprised because I hadn't even
thought of it is it a problem if in our
artificially intelligent system does
things that seem to be ethical to us but
it can't articulate why it's doing them
and this is an issue for deep learning
systems right where it can recognize a
picture but it can't tell us why it
recognized a picture a human being would
be able to articulate an answer that
might not be the correct reason why they
did something but at least it can try
should we expect the same from AI that's
a great question and the answer is I'm
not sure there's a Content position here
that says that it's not a real decision
getting back to you know the very first
thing we talked about it's not a
decision you're responsible for unless
you can actually articulate the reasons
for it you can't you can tell me why you
did it otherwise you're just sort of an
animal or a child acting on instinct now
to me it doesn't so much matter if you
can articulate it what matters is are
you following the maximun principle
right and I think the best way of doing
this is actually constructing the
maximun principle in these autonomous
systems in what's called a top-down
approach however I'm also open to the
possibility of what you might call
approximating a maximun principle
through these more bottom-up methods if
the machine learning system produced
outputs that always matched the maximun
principle in the kinds of cases we
observe and we had good reason for
thinking that it would continue to run
this program that up
approximated maximun in future cases
then I would say that would be let's say
close to good enough or sufficient in
that case I think so I mean I think it's
a little bit too much to demand of our
AI systems that they be articulate moral
philosophers as long as they seem to be
doing mostly the right things right well
as long as it says something like the
reason why I chose this path instead of
this path is that the worst collision in
this path is better than the worst
collision in that path it doesn't need
to say need to say something like I
traveled into the original position I
realized from there that maxime n was
actually yeah that'd be too much to ask
and the other final question was
something you already alluded to a
potential difference between the
everyday life circumstance of a car
driving around and trying to avoid
accidents and the everyday but not
everyone's life case of people at war or
you know machines that were
intentionally built in order to inflict
harm in a certain way how do the moral
considerations change I realize it's a
huge topic but you know maybe a simple
introduction to the differences between
that and everyday life in wartime well
the smallest case is that this might be
applied and right now are what you could
call security robots right and in fact
these are currently being used in some
airports and China and other places in
East Asia where they have in some cases
Taser technology equipped with them and
so there are good things about this kind
of technology and in fact if someone is
harming another person it is good if a
robot could step in and actually
neutralize the threat but the problem is
in doing so it needs to be capable of
identifying when there is a threat what
kind of threat this is and what the
proportional amount of force is to
neutralize that threat and so contract
Arianism does make predictions about
this if you could quantify the kind of
harm being done by that threatening
agent that enemy agent and you could say
usually that neutralizing the threat
is better than just say killing the
agent because that would be certainly
making the agent now worst off yeah but
neutralizing the threat would be the
best of all possible outcomes and so you
could imagine security robots and in the
extreme military robots being designed
with their goal of neutralizing enemies
and neutralizing threats because I think
that would be the maximun approach to it
right but maxy men seems to maybe I'm
just not accept Eliza you correctly but
it seems to fail us a little bit when
literally our goal is to kill people
that's right and I think that you could
imagine cases and I do imagine cases
where the ideal autonomous robot in war
would be commanded to kill an enemy
soldier and the robot would say no thank
you but I am going to apprehend him and
take him into prison right in fact
that's the goal I mean going back to our
good friend Immanuel Kant he famously
and shockingly said if God commands you
to kill your own children the correct
response is no I'm not going to do that
and we tell people in military ethics
and the ethics of war that if you're if
your commanding officer tells you to
kill innocent people and war the correct
answer is no but I am happy to do other
things that are not war crimes but do I
remember correctly the in the book you
suggested or at least wondered out loud
whether or not it might be okay to
ultimately have autonomous self-driving
cars or drones and so forth but not in
the theater of war that autonomy should
be always in the hands of human agents
who actually can take responsibility
that's right there was an there was a
letter that was recently signed by a
number of people who work on ethics and
political philosophy who and these these
group of people were arguing that
autonomous systems should not be used in
in war at all now I wouldn't go that far
but I would agree that the kinds of
capabilities
they would require in order to be I
don't want to use the word responsible
but in order to make the right choices
in war are unlikely to happen anytime
soon and so all of my all of my claims
are a big hypothetical which is if if we
are going to design these kinds of
machines these are the kinds of
capabilities that they would require and
I'm willing to do that for military
robots as well with more skepticism that
they are actually going to achieve this
level of sophistication then in the case
of medical technology or transportation
technology it's very interesting to me
because I see a philosophical version of
what happens in physics in particular in
science more generally where concepts
that we could have ignored at earlier
times are forced to the forefront of our
attention by the progress of technology
right and so this it's a it's a
wonderful thing I think it's a wonderful
thing for philosophy that our
discussions about morality are being
sharpened a little bit by the fact that
we can't be wishy-washy we can't be
fuzzy about them we can't just say be
excellent to each other we need to tell
you know
machines that will listen to us quite
literally how to behave in a wide
variety of circumstances yeah and you
know I have to admit a friend of mine
pushed me on this position that I take
he said it was kind of [ __ ] what I'm
doing because if I was taking a strong
moral stance against autonomous weapon
systems can I say [ __ ] on your
program absolutely ok so that it's kind
of [ __ ] and that I am being
hypocritical or I am I am not really
caring about the the the use of this
technology that in fact I'm just saying
if you're going to build it here's the
right way of doing it and I'm sensitive
to that objection I'm very sensitive to
it I'm not convinced that autonomous
weapon systems or autonomous vehicles or
autonomous medical care BOTS are
actually a good idea in the long run and
I'm sensitive to the fact that maybe
this position I'm taking
a little bit hmm to corporate well but
that that being said if any corporations
would like to pay me large amounts of
money I am more than available very good
well I do hope they take you up on that
I think that uh certainly on your side
in thinking that this is something where
we should face up to the problems rather
than ignore them
Derek Lee even thanks so much for being
on the podcast
thank you shot
you
[Music]
you
[Music]